un jour ou l'autre les humains
découvriront que nous sommes ici tu
aurais dû te douter que ce jour
viendrait
devrions nous suivre l'exemple de notre
roi et nous muré dans le silence comme
lui
vont aller sur terre maintenant
nous vivons cachés depuis trop longtemps
retournant l'atome non si nous étions
sur terre nous aurions alors une
glorieuse planète sur laquelle prospérer
et viseur qui serait prêt à trahir nos
frères à travers ton roi
une voie appelée
dans ses intentions qu'ils aient raison
tort il est dangereux
tout ce que je veux c'est la liberté la
liberté pour tous les cinémas camp
servir de t'avoir afin de tuer ton
propre frère
attrapez 2
[Musique]
barrer la route
nous allons prendre notre destin en main